[Music]
the hunt is on in the witcher season too
as fans of the witcher video games will
see some very familiar faces riding in
to run wild here's everything else that
meant more than you realized in the
witcher season 2.
as fans may know well by now geralt is
not known for being particularly
forthright for this witcher less is
always more he takes siri to the witcher
stronghold caramorin knowing that it
will keep her safe upon their approach
siri notes its run-down appearance he
offers a vague explanation telling her
there was an attack a long time ago when
i was a boy almost wiped this all out so
now we like to keep a low profile the
sacking of caramoran is devastating for
witchers and it's detailed in the anime
film the witcher nightmare of the wolf
the netflix film covers vesemir's
backstory in his youth he dreams of
escaping his misfortune and he goes on
to become a witcher and kill monsters
for coin in addition to this backstory
nightmare of the wolf details the
specifics of the downfall of karamorin a
powerful mage named tetra blames
witchers for the deaths of her family
and comes up with a plot to destroy them
this plan includes destroying mutagens
which results in the loss of any means
to create more witchers this backstory
gives more context to vesemir's grief
over losing ceres blood compound that
would have made more of his kind
part of siri's great loss is that she
never knew her parents as we see in
season one the law of surprise ensures
that even though geralt initially balks
at the idea siri's destiny is forever
tied to his and he is responsible for
her siri's birth parents are removed
from the picture the moment geralt helps
her father dooney secure dooney's union
with siri's mother vivetta however siri
was first raised by her grandmother
queen kalanthi who kept the details of
her lineage and fate a secret from her
geralt reveals to her that he was at her
parents wedding feast causing siri to be
intrigued because she has very little
knowledge about how her parents came to
be wed geralt never sugarcoats the truth
but he does leave specific details out
your grandmother
didn't want your mother marrying her
an outsider
true to form geralt is once again
lighter on the details omitting the fact
that siri's mother fell in love with her
father while he was pursed to look like
a hedgehog geralt does this as a
kindness not wanting to sully siri's
perception of her grandmother but he is
careful for another key reason he knows
exactly what it means to be an outsider
going through life he experiences
judgment from the world at large for
being a witcher he knows the pain that
brings and what it is like to remain on
the outside
being a parent is a core theme of the
witcher season two until now geralt
spent most of his life alone only having
to care for himself and his horse roach
parenthood albeit surrogate fatherhood
is new to him and he doesn't always do
the right thing
when geralt and siri traveled to
cairmorin vasamir advises him on the
truths of being a parent
geralt often expects siri to do as she's
told and quickly realizes that raising a
child is not as easy as bending a child
to one's will he learns this especially
after the death of his brother in arms
eskel askal is infected by a lesson and
turned into a monster after geralt is
forced to kill him vesemir laments the
loss telling geralt if it were your
child you'd be going crazy to figure it
out what you missed
what you could have done differently
the witchers at karamorin are like sons
to him and his grief is powerful at the
time geralt feels like he can sympathize
with vesamir's emotions he is a father
of sorts now and would do anything for
siri but he doesn't fully understand the
overwhelming weight of parenthood until
later after bringing siri to a temple so
she can learn to control her chaos he
reunites with yennefer though the
reunion is romantic at first geralt
quickly learns his mistake in trusting
her jennifer steals siri in a bid to
reinstate her power geralt is not
especially surprised at yennefer's
actions but feels the heartache of
losing someone who is effectively his
child
stregabor is easily one of the most
detestable antagonists in the witcher he
operates with no morals asking estred to
spy on yennefer due to her elven blood
in season one he makes no show of hiding
his prejudices and outwardly hurts
people for his own enjoyment this
includes his treatment of yennefer in
season two because she is a quarter elf
nilfgaard's alignment with the elves
calls her loyalty into question fueled
by suspicions that she is a spy
stregabor tortures her trying to enter
her mind for secrets he defends his
actions by stating that all he ever
cared about was protecting their society
and he tells a group of mages as much in
episode three i've always tried to
protect our institutions to protect
you
but this is a weak defense strega bore
has often exhibited hatred of women he
refers to yennefer as being lesser
because of her blood the only thing
central hates more than mages is
elves
this attitude is a mirror from season
one and his treatment of renfree renfree
was among 60 girls born during a lunar
eclipse because of this stregabor
decreed that they should all be killed
renfree kills for pleasure she is a
monster she is the last of lilith's
women
renfree suffered at the hands of
stregabor and his abuses continued into
the present timeline
stroke aboard's man raped me
robs me and let me go he uses the excuse
that he is doing it for his people when
he is really just prejudiced
many plot points have been teased and
built up since the first episode of the
witcher series however an element that
fans of the show may not be familiar
with materializes in the final episode
after siri geralt and yennefer dispel
voleth mare in a parallel sphere the
newfound family sees something they did
not expect a horde of ghostly writers
charging them
child of the elder blood
starry-eyed daughter of chaos
after they portal back to safety siri
knows they aren't completely safe yet
geralt confirms her suspicions merely
saying those riders are the wild hunt
also known as the wraiths of morhawk the
wild hunt will be integral to the
witcher world going forward the ghost
riders are set up in andrei sapkowski's
books and are heavily featured in the
witcher 3 video game these writers are
intent on capturing slaves and they mark
siri as their next target her elder
blood draws them to her and makes her
desirable because of how powerful she is
the introduction of the wild hunt is
only the start of the plot line
involving this terrifying antagonist
from the witcher cannon siri and her new
family will have to look out for it in
season three
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the witcher are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]